We keep finding planets HUNDREDS of them!
But once we find a planet... then what do
we do with it?
Hey everybody, Trace here with your Weekly
DNews Space Update.
The first exoplanet was discovered in 1992,
and since then we've confirmed 1800 more.
But discerning anything about these planets
is pretty difficult, because they're so far
away.
To simplify the discovery of these exoplanets
NASA launched a planet-hunting telescope named
after the famous 17th century astronomer Johannes
Kepler.
This week, scientists at NASA announced Kepler's
namesake, in spite of being broken, discovered
715 new planets!
To date, they've found indications of over
3,500 planets, but what do we KNOW about these
alien worlds?
Well, not a lot.
It's really difficult to FIND planets orbiting
far away stars and we've never seen one up
close.
The farthest camera from our sun is Voyager
1 -- and it's barely passed out of our solar
system.
What we can usually determine is the number
of planets orbiting a star, the masses of
those planets and their relative sizes.
The research depends on excellent observation
and timing paired with state of the art equipment.
Armed with all of these, researchers at CalTech
discovered water on a planet 51 light-years
from Earth.
It's called Tau Boötis b.
Though scientists have found water vapor on
planets before, the method these researchers
used is new!
Tau Boötis b is what's called a "hot Jupiter"
because it is close to its sun, and about
the size of our Jupiter.
Prior to this new method, we had to be watching
at the moment one of these gas giants passed
in front of its star in order to perceive
evidence of water.
If we missed it, or were at the wrong angle
-- no dice.
But now, astronomers at the Keck Observatory
in Hawaii are using the Near Infrared Echelle
Spectrograph to determine the glow of a planet's
atmosphere to discern the light wavelengths
emitted by different molecules.
In other words, they can now look at a planet's
glow to determine if a planet has WATER.
Spectrographs are used by chemists; you've
probably seen them on CSI and other forensics
shows.
They use thing learned in 20th century chemistry
to analyze the chemical fingerprint molecules.
For example: atoms of oxygen, sodium or carbon
absorb or reflect specific wavelengths of
light -- so every molecule has its own fingerprint
of colors and hues, and by using infrared,
this spectrograph reveals even MORE information.
Using this new technique, astronomers can
determine which elements are in the atmosphere
of a planet light-years away just by pointing
their telescope at it..
MIND.
BLOWN.
I mean, this equipment is pretty standard
science fare, but for astronomers looking
at exoplanets, it's pretty cool.
Using this new method we can point telescopes
at planets all over the visible universe and
determine what KIND of planet that is.
If we point it at those in green-zones -- or
a human habitable planet zone -- and find
water, nitrogen and oxygen in the atmosphere,
we'll be able to make a map of planets likely
to support Earth-like life!
Astronomy is fantastic, old school science.
I looked through a telescope for the first
time when I was a kid and it was breathtaking...
Have you ever tried it?
Tell us below in the comments and thanks for
watching!
See you next week for another Space Friday.